[Music]
in shower thoughts news oh it's my
stomach flu for you Oh for you yeah our
food poisoning where are the fudge no
stomach flu
I heard it's just flu and then they just
there's like stomachache there's no such
thing is I think it's just another way
of saying food poisoning yeah sometimes
I I do that where it's like I meant food
poisoning you get a fever and you get
flu-like symptoms and then you're
throwing up you're [ __ ] do you know
what happened you know that lettuce
thing that's going around cold I just
actually had the e.coli cuz then she had
a Caesar salad and then she was puking
for a couple days recently no this was
like a month ago
I won't hear some gangster [ __ ] though
yeah I read that ecoli [ __ ] right
I ordered a Caesar salad anyways and I
was fine my dude like Russian Roulette
right now man I said I don't give a [ __ ]
that's very surprising for you you'll
hear the real story though yeah I salad
I found out after that's the real story
as long as you drink afterward and jump
up and down you want to watch these you
get this true poisonings I did not and
I'm thinking it's because I had like 10
shots after so I might have been melted
them [ __ ] I think the alcohol killed it
that's smart
yeah yeah smart man I didn't get it so I
think I got pretty lucky the most
profound shower thoughts have been
compiled in a recent subreddit shower
thoughts are the best I have [ __ ]
thoughts like when I'm on that toilet
and I didn't really remember something
it's usually it comes to me when I'm
taking a [ __ ] cuz all the [ __ ]
leaves and then you have your kids but
then don't you spit on with your
telephone Oh on this on the [ __ ]
always yeah so to me it's very different
because it's the same as sitting down if
I'm fiddling with this but if I'm doing
this it gives me time to think cuz I'm
not focused on life you know yeah these
are more like when they look like deep
into things so for example the first one
here the generation that protested
Vietnam due to the senseless killings of
young people are now criticizing young
people for standing up to senseless
killings next one some day the first
half of your life has ended but you
won't know it what does that mean why do
you waste time like you're 50 and you're
like oh my first half
my life is gone like that well you will
never know when the hacker would like
people you don't know where you're gonna
die that's kind of an obvious Vietnam
you know how many people were [ __ ]
dying in Vietnam it was insane yeah it
was insane
I think the hippies that supported the
stop of Vietnam are still trying to stop
like all kinds of violence and [ __ ] so I
don't know what the hell they're talking
about
I'm gonna uppercut this [ __ ]
next one a boxer can't be a sore loser
and a good sport
simultaneously uh-huh a boxer can be a
sore loser and a good sport simultaneous
Wow
this shit's weak you yeah it's uh this
shit's a corporate for drinks vennu
mallesh philosophy yeah I'm a good and
bad boy I'm a very good bad boy this is
typical reddit wisdom oh man this guy
sucks up being a Python okay or maybe
I'm just too stupid I don't get it
because I am a very good bad boy I am a
sore loser good sport yes the next one
the seven deadly sins are just survival
instincts which society has deemed
inappropriate because they favor the
individual and not the group what's the
seven deadly sins Let Me In is insert
this in survival instinct though yeah
that's terrible because animals don't do
that fasting is a survivalist Nick I
almost don't gluttonous no they don't
keep eating until they die here crazy
fat are you sure
yeah they eat walking facts he didn't
know he got a while he's domesticated so
he's living human behavior wait so what
are the seven deadly sins this is the
appropriate response to shower thoughts
by the way it's lust blending hurry the
[ __ ] up you're wasting all the hot water
huh
lust gluttony Envy I want to know what
less gluttony Envy pride that's all I
got going right greed lust Envy gluttony
wrath and sloth wrath and Slauson for
not profit sloth laziness a good slow
lazy [ __ ] jannat merely I am
although seven deadly sins no you're not
sloth anymore I know I fixed that [ __ ]
you're a lust
you're not greedy unless none of these
never mind
who you are you're not lust who's not
lust who's not lust I stand up and show
yourself I don't have much deal yourself
damn mafia I know I think the seven
deadly sins is like everybody so damn
profound will you set the bar oh yeah -
so then do you put your point I think
this evidently Sansa is everybody I'm
trying to do shower thoughts right now
you know we're bad and we're good put
myself in his mindset let's see if it
blows not to say anything negative about
this article but what is this list about
a little lost
okay so let's roll if everyone was
cremated we'd have less to worry about
if there was a zombie apocalypse very
true very true as high thoughts but if
you think I mean it's another version of
what hang high do you think zombies can
come out of caskets because if you're
six feet honor there's [ __ ] all this
dirt you can't [ __ ] yourself that's a
bad that's not profound episode okay
next one the reason for the good guys
always win trope is because throughout
history the victors write the textbooks
and they always think they're the good
guys that's true that's true cats really
want that I don't but what qualifies a
shower thought though I'm so confused
just let it be it's just a week it's
like a whole thing
yeah I think it's cuz when I shot way
different things up what do you think of
like for example like the other day when
I was I do think of a lot of recipes
others but that's a given though I do
that before I sleep and I shower you do
that while he's jacking off here mmm
not anymore Oh pastrami no but we had
like I'll think of [ __ ] like this like
what would have happened if I think
about a lot of what-ifs
Oh give me one so for example I thought
about like what if I stay with my very
first girlfriend like where would I be
at right now oh you live in Nepal I
don't live in the past
I just think about how life can be a lot
of different trajectories yeah and so
like that Ashton Kutcher was think about
yeah
well it's just fascinating because I
look at it like this right so my very
first girlfriend from her dumping me to
Who I am now that was a huge catalyst to
the reason why I'm as successful as I
have now because you're hot broke and
then you say I'm gonna prove to you by
the way you never heard of her my whole
life it was more like this it was like
exactly thank you very much David so it
was more like this is like I I
identified who I was as a person because
of her so like I was such a loser that I
thought if she told me that I was
important then I was an important person
so when I broke up with her it helped me
self reflect you know when she brought
me it made me self reflect I was like oh
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] loser you know I mean
so all I could picture at the time was a
white picket fence marrying this girl
and having a kid and that's as far as my
dreams went so when we broke up that
dream shattered and I was like hold on
said it my world's this big and then it
helped me evolve as a person so that's
the type of wish that I think about when
that's a [ __ ] shower thought yeah it
just goes into this weird like bass
excellent
what kind of made me giggle our power
grid is just a massive highway system
for squirrels
that's a shower cause also there's like
marble you know like the marble granite
stones I look for faces in there oh okay
I mean this may be really weird but when
I was little and like I'd be on the
toilet just because I would be wasting
time forever I'll just be there and then
I would I would touch tiles in a certain
pattern into my mind that would open
like unleash this different world that
was my imagination I think I was like
that's pretty dope currently right now I
thought there's a girl in the granite
that's very happy a black lady with
dreads playing a saxophone ooh yeah so
she's like those are trapped falls at
the wall oh no that like caps holes in
the wall
scared I did but they're not happy so I
did think about their job there's also
one with the ghoul scaring directly at
me so they're in wall heaven have you
tell a kid it's like hey don't worry
throwing wall having the kids like yep
good advice cool thing before you go
shower
those are trapped Souls oh all right
shower thought someone that tells you
not to take advice from them because
they give bad advice it's technically
good advice that's true it's like don't
listen to me I'm stupid yeah I always
tell people that next one
we can only describe smells by comparing
them to other smells yeah or take ok
that's true in color color too right
you can't really compare I don't know
about Co that's ridiculous I can't
describe color I can't describe taste
though that's the most absurd thing I've
ever heard I like their own way do they
yeah they do because all of us bring in
like different all that is red he
validated you know people with light
colored eyes they see different colors
from brown color eyes because they bring
in way more lights rival colors booklet
of colors Pantone book just give the
number that's it that that's the color I
want you will never know yeah the same
color yeah they might see peach you know
what that makes sense maybe that's why
so many Asian people have gold Camrys
because that [ __ ] is hideous they love
it they think it's amazing next one
most fences aren't that secure they just
take advantage of our laziness Oh to
break in oh it depends I mean some of
them have those spikes on the top
they're pretty like yeah those are
pretty sturdy like when I was a kid
scaling fences I was like I'll [ __ ]
these ones if that barbed wire yeah but
everything else I like it's easy I'll
hop this book like nothing yeah we'll
the one the black ones with the those
those arrow spikes the top a hot dose is
really the 12 footers oh just
neighborhood ones Olga what else is
there
ah
let's make fun of them one of the worst
feelings is your sleeve sliding down as
you wash your hands no one of the worst
feelings is acid in your face in your
eyes I think that beats it a little bit
man
yeah I think that's probably one of the
worst feelings actually this person's a
little [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are they
complaining about you don't want to
leave for the rest of the day it's like
then you want to cheat like I get it I
get it
well worst feelings is going to the bank
and finding you had no money now the
water does is coming home and finding
out that your ex-wife took away your
kids you know one of the worst feelings
is your dog eats your kid when you're
gone one of the worst feelings is you go
to a steak house and you finish it and
then you find out the steak was actually
your grandma and the chef's [ __ ] cook
there yeah I think that's one of the
worst feelings that's so funny dude like
that's hilarious cuz somebody would be
like okay well today my wife accused me
of raping and taking away my kids well
[ __ ] you I have wet sleeves you guess
what up you know my socks a little bit
soggy
so uh that's probably the worst feeling
[ __ ] complain to me [ __ ] last one
here sleep is like a trial version of
death while I love trying out that thing
this is what people think about cuz I
must be like a little bit different than
most people because I don't think that
way to be honest with you I've read way
better shower thoughts but this article
I was submitted heavy snow but I can't
find the other one but usually I'll come
across them like on my feed from a lot
of the meme accounts yeah a lot of dope
one I love imagination or I love
listening to other peoples like thoughts
and whatever these thoughts made me feel
like oh I'm bored listening to you and
thinking like wow cuz I got a piece of
how they think right and I'm like wow
you're [ __ ] boring this is your
shower thought I'm getting sad like I'm
getting depressed being in that [ __ ]
wavelength
maybe it's bath time you know I mean
yeah for some of these people
[Music]